我们来看一下千与千寻这部电影，这个片子定性是不需要讨论的啊。
跟绿野仙踪一毛一样。
讲的是。
一个少女或者是一个小孩吧的一些担忧和想象啊，把他生活当中的一些嗯他想象的东西形成了一个奇幻的冒险啊，先看一下。
故事节拍，由于这个日本电影啊分段也不也不是那么的清晰。因为日本电影其实是跟主流的商业电影一直保持着这个距离啊。所以我们尝试也给它分一分吧。这是一个标准的儿童片。同学们，咱们。
拉片拉了这么多，就这一部是儿童片，虽然里面有纯纯的爱情，但是不耽误它是个儿童片，儿童也有爱情的向往啊。
所有要写儿童片的同学今天给我竖起耳朵。好吧，第一拍讲的是千寻很不情愿的跟随爸妈搬去乡下，这是一个很重要的起点。他不情愿不开心，这时候才会胡思乱想，才会瞎担心，这是一个想象的起点。我刚才也讲过。
整个电影讲的是千寻的一个想象。
他脑补的一些事情，那里面必然会。
是生活当中各种东西的投射，他喜欢的东西，他害怕的东西，对不对？
为什么烧锅炉子啊也是个大蜘蛛呀，对不对？平常害怕蜘蛛嘛？这个汤婆婆是个是个大乌鸦，是不是害怕乌鸦嘛，都是投射。所以说从开始的时候，我们先接受这个定性，然后拉片的时候，脑子里面给我装置这件事情去揣摩一下人家为什么要这么写。
儿童片是怎么想象出来的？
为什么这部片子看起来松松垮垮的主角的主动性也一般，说实话阻力也一般，对吧？很多人到最后都变好了，然后呢哎但是依然很震撼。
让我们觉得心灵为之震撼，除了配乐加持以外，那必然剧情上也有让我们震撼的东西。我们看一下儿童片是怎么写出来的，好不好？上来不情愿搬去乡下，这是我们小时候都会共情的东西。父母做了一个决定。
我们没有决定权，被迫要根据父母的工作变动，根据父母的事情，我们要放弃我们自己的生活，去搬去一个新的地方。这就是第一拍。为什么你能快速入戏？
我们都经历过我们的童年，我们其实都记得，只是有时候想不起来，就是。
电影当中的词儿对不对？小时候我们也有这种创伤。
我们都记得，只是我们长大了想不起来了，所以才会震撼啊，这是第一拍第二拍。
第二分钟开错路啊，开始各种不好的暗示。
路上各种东西啊，各然后突然出现了一座建筑，冒险进入啊冒险进入。
第三拍第6分钟啊，在废弃的建筑群里探险，发现了好吃的。然后父母呢不顾着不顾千寻的劝阻，大快朵颐。第四拍第十分钟，千寻呢独自去寻找探索。
碰到那个男孩子啊，那个男孩子告诉他，天黑之前必须离开，碰到一个男孩子警告他啊，我们说先跟这个男孩子相遇。
然后在逃离过程，发现鬼怪逐渐显现，父母也变成了猪。原来这是一个怪物街，自己走不掉了啊。
第五拍14分钟，奇幻的世界啊正式在他面前展开，开始出现了各种怪事儿，包括千寻自己啊也变得透明了。还是刚才那个男孩子来帮助他告诉他吃了这个世界的东西就能保住自己，对吧？
然后呢，那就。
这个他还是想找自己的爸妈向这个小白表达了啊。然后汤婆婆呢，我们后面知道是汤婆婆，现在是谁还不知道他是叫汤婆婆在天空当中搜寻啊，发现这儿有人吗？第六拍16分钟。
跟着男孩逃跑啊，分飞奔，而且还要屏住哭吸。为了去找爸妈要先活下去呀。
然后呢，嗯得知得去找锅炉爷爷啊，去找那个大蜘蛛。
呃，并且告诉他了路径和方法啊，第一个路径有了。第七拍来了20分钟，白先生呢帮他呃就是这个小白帮他引开这个注意，千寻偷偷的来到了锅炉房，向锅炉爷爷啊，其实是个大蜘蛛去求职，但是被拒绝了。第八拍27分钟。嗯，帮助运梅啊，还是被拒绝。
结果这个送饭的姐姐来了啊，发现了陈寻，锅炉爷爷保护了他，然后呢让他带他让那个带他去见汤婆婆啊。第九拍进入第二个场景。汤屋3第九拍的31分钟啊，一路上展示整个汤屋的这个这个这个展示啊，实际上就是个洗浴中心啊。
北方的同学应该比较熟悉，就是一个洗浴。嗯，在日本可能叫汤屋吧，是吧？这个韩国叫汤泉是吧？
嗯，这个这个这个一个一个一个喜浴啊。
然后开始展现各种奇奇怪怪的东西啊嗯这个。
正式踏上啊各种奇幻的旅程，然后来到了楼顶见这个汤婆婆。第十拍啊，36分钟向这个汤婆婆求职。嗯，然后汤婆婆呢用嘴巴交用台词交代了这是个什么地方啊，叫稍微交代一下背景吧，这是个神明洗澡的地方啊嗯。
然后他的父母因为偷吃东西被罚了。
那个我们的千寻啊非常坚持要在这儿找份工作，然后签下了一个契约。当然后面我们知道这也是汤婆婆的一个伎俩啊，给他改名字，让他叫小千，希望他忘记原本的名字。
1一拍41分钟，白先生呢就小白带着小千。
把它分配给刚才那个做饭的那个小玲，小玲还是挺照顾他的啊，帮助他安顿下来。但是这个白先生现在就是小白现在看不透啊，到底是干嘛的，看不透。1二盘来到44盘，44分钟，这个小白又来找他说能带他去见父母去了之后发现这两头猪呢已经不认识他了啊。
然后呢，承诺要把父母救出去，我们谦寻了算是这个阶段的主要目标啊呃到最后也是这个目标也一直在啊，要把父母救出去。
然后藏好了父母的衣服，嗯，包括小白会告诉他，你一定要记住自己的名字，你叫千寻啊，这很关键，忘了这个名字就走不掉了。
十三拍来到52分钟啊，开始上班干活啊，呃又遇到那个隐形的无脸男啊呃帮自己搞定了那个药浴，因为要需要药浴啊，去洗这个什么一号池之类的啊，反正就是一个无脸男嗯一个伙伴嘛。
因为后面我们发现小白是爱情啊，这无脸男是伙伴，所以在第二幕里面纷纷都遇到了呃，都往前推进了。
14拍呢58分钟来了一个什么腐烂之神啊，这个这个挺恶心的，所有人都抗拒。还要千寻作为一个新人啊，接受了这个任务，要给对方这个帮对方洗澡。
然后呢，用刚才他得到的那些药浴牌子坚持不懈的洗啊，最后还发现这个客人身上有个刺儿，有个塞子啊，给人拔掉了，最后发现对方是河神啊，河神这个洗爽了啊洗爽了。
帮店里赚了一大笔钱，算是立功了啊立功。
十5拍啊，67分钟千寻吃饭畅想着未来。然后当然了也交代了一下，他从和神那拿拿了一个丸子，啊，不知道是不是济公的丸子是一个类型啊。吴脸男那里继续推进他那个伙伴啊，吴脸男嗯开始制造危机，把青蛙给吃了啊。
十6拍71分钟，新的一天，这个吴猎男已经在这个汤屋搞事情了啊，疯狂吃喝，疯狂撒钱呃，工作人员很开心啊，都在那赚钱。嗯，但是千寻牵挂着父母，他不顾着他顾不上这件事情。而且他看到这个白龙小白被攻击啊，帮着小白。
去脱困。
1七拍来到75分钟，千寻呢想要上楼去找汤婆婆，但是受阻。然后另外一边呢无脸男发飙了啊，拿着金子诱惑大家，但其实把大家给吃掉了，开始吃人了。1八拍77分钟，这个千寻只能爬天梯到楼顶啊，得知了汤婆婆要除掉白龙。
因为他刚才看到白龙被攻击嘛，他上来就是来救白龙的。我们说后面这个小白是他的爱情啊，然后呢遇到了汤婆婆的那个孪生姐妹啊，钱婆婆。
然后坠下深渊到了底层锅炉房。
十九拍来到86分钟，刚才不是得了河神的丸子吗？拿那个丸子救这个白龙，然后白龙吐出了魔法印章啊。其实本意就是康婆婆派白龙去前婆婆那里偷了一个魔法印章。但是这个魔法印章在这个白龙身体里面呢会反噬白龙啊，导致白龙奄奄一息。
然后而且从这个锅路爷爷那里得知了白龙的呃来历，他其实也是个人，只不过来了之后由于最新模法哈，想要学技术，然后嘞把自己的名字给忘了，回不去了。
然后千寻就想救救白龙啊，想把这个印章还给钱婆婆救白龙。然后锅炉爷爷呢给他指明了方向，而且告诉他，而且给了他一个车票，20拍91分钟啊，要离开汤屋去前婆婆那里换场景了啊，基本上也就换第三部了。呃，这部戏一共三部啊。
走之前呢解决一下无脸男的那个危机啊，解决的也比较容易，挺好说话的。喂给无脸男另外一半丸子啊，一人一半。然后无脸男呢就呕吐暴走啊，变虚弱，实际上变好了，然后正式成为了千寻的伙伙伴啊，跟千寻走了。21拍97分钟，千寻踏上了。
新的征途，然后带着三个小伙伴。
我们说踏上新的征途，带上三个小伙伴，是不是又是绿野仙踪和西游记啊？
对吧带着铁皮人，那个稻草人和狮子是吧？而且去找新的一个巫婆，然后新的巫婆能解决他们的问题，对吧？而且这两个巫婆还是姐妹儿，这不就是绿叶仙踪吗？
啊，21拍97分钟，千寻大新的征途，带着三个小伙伴啊坐着列车去远方。
然后22拍101分钟回到汤屋那里，白龙苏醒了，寻找千寻啊呃，然后这时候汤婆婆威胁要杀掉那两头猪，其实就千寻的爸妈嘛，然后白龙提醒汤婆婆，他的东西已经被钱婆婆掉包了啊，嗯，暂时把千寻的父母保住了，并且提出一个交换条件。
说我给你想办法，你你把那个呃他的父母放了，你可以理解，千寻去到远方是为了救小白。小白在这里是要救千寻的父母，两个人算是互相拯救，双向奔赴。因为理论上，千寻重最重要的任务是要救。
父母。
这个主线目标其实不能轻易换的。但是现在为什么换了呢？首先因为小白是爱情还蛮重要的对吧？第二呢，小白能救他的父母，虽然这个不明说，但是这里小白自己给把这件事情给明出来了。这样的话导致两个人双向奔赴这个爱情算是能成立。
这个目标也没有拉胯啊。
23拍来到106分钟，四个人继续赶路啊，来了一个油灯指路，终于赶到了钱婆婆的家里，归还印章啊，请求原谅呃，请求解除魔法。
嗯，发现钱婆婆也非常好说话，也是个好人啊。
给出了一定的线索。
千寻呢非常担心这个这个白龙和自己的父母。然后呢，这个钱婆婆给了他一个大家共同编织的一个护身护身符。
一个护身符25拍，112分钟，白龙他们来了啊，白龙又来了，两个人团聚了，一块飞翔回家。等于来到前婆坡这儿呢，实际嗯也没有起到太大的作用，就拿了个护身符。
然后26拍114分钟回去的路上，两个人在天上飞的路上，千寻想起了小时候的那条河流琥珀川啊，然后也导致白龙想起了自己的名字，变回了人形。
原来两人小时候就有渊源。
我在课上给大家讲过啊，爱情如果要快速展开爱情，由于在一个多小时里面，有时候很难把爱情讲透。一般来说，影视作品都会选择男女主是有渊源的，小时候有救命之恩，小时候有媒妁之言，懂吧？有信物，曾经。
送给我信物，但我们又分开了，对吧？我们说这种都是常用套路啊，救命之恩我们见的太多了，从新新白娘子是吧？
白娘那个白蛇传是不是？
这个这个呃科长都给大家讲过啊。
这种都是两个人的相遇。嗯，由于很难做的惊天动地，那最好就是之前有渊源啊。
27拍116分钟，两个人一块回到堂屋，又跟唐婆婆交换条件是吧？嗯，宝宝起了很大的作用啊，唐婆婆是个宝宝奴嘛，对吧？
然后呢就发现汤伯婆人也没有很坏，也并不是说一定要赶情杀绝，就很痛快的大眼形还给你。但是你要在一群猪里找出真的秋香，是吧？否则就把秋香就不嫁给你了啊。我们说这个唐伯虎点秋香里面啊，最后也是这个结局，就是这个发现这个人并不坏啊，因为是个儿童片嘛。
没有什么十恶不赦的人是吧？最后发现没有坏人。嗯，但是我们这个千寻非常厉害啊，这个就说这里面没有没有我爸妈啊，也跟这个唐伯虎剪秋香的故事一样啊。
28拍118分钟啊，两个人分别了啊，千寻踏上了回归的路啊，和父母团聚，嗯，一切都没有发生，回到车里啊，这个这个还在期待白龙的出现。但其实一切都没有发生。嗯，整个故事就结束了。嗯，通过我之前给大家讲，我们说这是一个。
小女孩被迫要去到一个新的地方，对新的地方的一些担心、担忧、不情愿以及生活当中的一些不满，对吧？生活当中一些被误解。
他的或者是他的一些本来就害怕的东西，形成的这样一个呃儿纯纯的儿童片啊，我们说这是标准的儿童故事。呃，大家可以理解为什么在118分钟。
白龙也明明想起了自己是谁，但是白龙其实这时候已经想起自己是谁了，但是他为什么不回到人间呢？因为白龙如果跟他一块儿出来，这不就坐实了吗？
对不对？不就坐实了嘛？所以白龙也没有说出什么原因，就说。
我不能再往前走了。
但是我会回到人间的。
我们说整个片子啊跟绿野仙踪一样。
是一个啊标准的一个儿童片啊，当然了，有些同学会有争执啊，说哎呀，我觉得肯定是发生过。
当然了，这个你怎么理解都行嘛。还有很多片子，千寻坐在回回重新坐上父母的车，然后父母开着他车往前走一伸手。
发现一个纸片人跟他出来。
是吧也有这种啊，不用太去定性啊，很多同学就特别理科脑啊，就觉得不行，一122必须给我说明白是吧？
不需要啊不需要搞得那么清楚啊，这呃本来就是个儿童片啊，总体上来说。
这个片子讲的就是一个小女孩的想象啊，当然可以再讲点悬的乎的啊，随便加。然后我们说这个电影啊呃。
为什么？
比较能够产生共鸣啊，其实主要还是基于这一点，就是他比较恰当，比较准确的拿捏了一个孩子，或者是我们每个人。因为戏里面讲嘛，我们每个人其实都记得这些事情，只不过有时候想不起来了啊，这些东西都在我们记忆当中。比如说。
我们说故事的主场景为什么发生在？
故事的主场景为什么发生在这个这个一个澡堂子？是因为我们小时候在记忆初期的时候，是我们的世界里只有父母。
你第一次去去澡堂子，看到那么多裸体，确实是印象很深的，而且是有点恐怖的。
你们记不记得来千寻第一次进到汤屋坐电梯碰到的那个人。
就是这种场景啊，我们说。
为什么这部戏在。
在无声无息当中就震撼到我们了。因为确实你第人生第一次去到澡堂子，看到全都是裸体的人，然后还有那些特别胖的。
然后全身所有的东西都瞎垂，然后奇奇怪怪，又白又胖。然后你又觉得想离他远一点，但是他又偏偏挤到你。我们说这些东西全都是。
全都是我们小时候经历过的，然后包括那个巨婴，对吧？它就是字面意义上的巨婴呀。
一个妈宝嘛。
然后我们害怕的蜘蛛乌鸦，然后呃贪吃会变成猪，然后不能忘记自己的名字，然后天黑会有坏事发生。
这些都是一个小孩儿记忆当中的东西啊。
但是小孩记忆当中没有什么呢？
没有善恶。
没有绝对的坏人。
所以在儿童片里面没有绝对的坏人。
河神也不坏，无脸男也不坏，后来还蛮可爱的。而且无脸男成为这个片子，后来成为这个片子的重要IP了，其实没多少戏份，对吧？然后整个片子啊是一个小女孩去调整自己的心态的一次呃奇幻的冒险啊，算是一次成长。
啊，通过他的幻想的一次成长，这是整个片子的一个定义，最后还是善良就能击败一切啊，你只要愿意去帮助别人。然后整个片子的打点呢当然有目标。我们刚才说了啊，这个片打点并不明确。我们也我们也说过这个片子呢本身从叙事上来讲啊。
肯定不是出类拔萃的。
想象力是出类拔萃的，配乐是出类拔萃的，整个给人的感觉，细腻程度肯定是出类拔萃的，情感的营造是出类拔萃的。但是叙事讲事情讲的并不好。
嗯，整个打点来说，我们既可以以千寻寻找爸妈作为主线打点，也可以以千寻和小白的情感发展作为打点。因为后面他们俩的这条爱情线还是比较明的。但是作为一个儿童片的爱情，我们说儿童啊，小朋友并不是没有爱情，小朋友也会喜欢一个异性。
也会觉得哎呀我想跟他在一起。
但是是很纯洁的啊是很纯洁的。
我们说这两种打点方式都有。
因为最后的大高潮是两个人互相拯救，并不是直接去救爸妈。两个人互相拯救之后，爸妈自然就得救了。
所以说这个打点啊不太明确啊。
我们来看一下这类片子的创作方法吧。我们今天最重要的要学会从小孩子的视角去写儿童故事。你将来不管是写动画片也好，还是写儿童电影也好啊，像这种类型的故事，一定要学会一件事，从孩子的视角去思考问题。
他们害怕什么？他们害怕大蛤蟆。
是吧他们害怕什么？
害怕大蜘蛛对吧？他们担心什么，担心天黑，担心想不起自己的名字，担心吃多了变成猪，从这个视角去考虑问。
这是儿童篇最重要的一个一个东西。儿童篇还有一个重要的东西，就是我们不可能光说这些元素是儿童片，儿童还有儿童自己的思维方式呀。比如说他认为善良就可以善良就可以解决问题。世界上没有什么太坏的人，我们大家只要善良。
别人也善良。
所以最后是善良化解了一切，这才是这部片子。这才是这部片子啊。我们最需要去学习的东西。他为什么让我们看完之后觉得哎呀心里暖暖的，还挺震撼的，还挺回味的。虽然我们说。
你说人物塑造吧能有多特殊得多特别，多鲜明，无脸男甚至连个人设都没有，对吧？你说故事结构吧，能有什么跌宕起伏，办了什么事儿，动了什么脑子把父母救回来了嘛？好像都没有，但是依然哎。
这样我们觉得挺好看的，是因为他做到了这些事情，他唤起了我们的童心。我们在这看这部片子的时候，都被宫崎骏变成了儿童了。
有个同学说，小孩子不是觉得世界上除了好人就是坏人吗？你看你这个思维方式又是一个大人的思维方式。
从小孩子的角度，他当然会觉得这个人是坏人，但是这个人是坏人，是因为他长得很凶。
小孩子并不会脑补，说这个人是坏人，因为他唯利是图，因为他心狠手辣，他想不到嘛。
能理解我在说什么吗？
他就是觉得凶巴巴的而已。
所以说从孩子的角度，他定义的坏人，他就是这样的。
童真嘛这种类型的片子我们看一个学一个就够了。
关键思路是从孩子角度思考。因为前段时间也有同也有这个这个。
呃，公司邀请我们一起做儿童动画片啊呃嗯被我拒绝了。
确实我说你让我现在让我现在四十有二的一个年纪。
从孩子的角度去思考问题，我我担心我做不到了。
同学们，如果你有这方面的需求，或者是有这方面的。
这个这个意愿啊，从这部片子学会最重要的东西。这部片子交布会我们做人设，交布会，我们做叙事，没有必要啊没有必要。
但是。
我们要学会他这种思考方式，宫崎骏之所以成为大师，是因为他一直保持着童真啊，参考类型的片子啊，绿野仙踪。
菊次郎的夏天菊次郎的夏天有同学记着吧？菊次郎的夏天我在课上也讲过，你甚至都可以把菊次郎的夏天理解成。
正南的。
对他要去远方找妈妈这个探险的一次想象，因为他去不了。
他没有这个能力。
也没有一路上那么多好人帮助他。
骑机车的飞车党小偷都是好人，都帮助他。在路上抢钱的大叔也帮助他。
帮助一个小孩去远方找自己的妈妈。
你可以理解也是正南的。
在一个夏天，由于非常思念自己的母亲。
谈脑补，哎呀，我们村最厉害的就是在村口抢钱的那个小流氓。嗯，他如果能陪我去就好了。
对吧然后去一路上，所有人都是善良的，所有人都帮助我。
也可以这么理解啊，所以我说菊次郎的夏天是作者回到自己的童年啊，写了一个儿童篇。今天借这个机会回去再把绿野仙踪和菊次郎的夏天看一看，好不好？那两两部片子，不光可以学习儿童片的写法，也可以学习一下。
啊，公路片来。
有同学说，动漫电影剧作创作时候有什么要注意的啊，就是给大人看的那种吧？给大人看的那些什么天刚传什么那种其实主要还是画面感，画面感要更强。因为人家的画面画面的尺度可以更大。如果你看动画片分很多种啊，动画只是一种呈现形式，我们不能说动画片就是给孩子看。
肯定不是这样啊，这部片子是给儿童看的。但是动画片我们说你说的那些其实是给大人看的，只不过他用动画来呈现那种片子在写剧本的时候，跟真人的片子最大的区别是画面想象力你可以更大。
好吧，这这部片子我再强调一下啊，人设和结构上嘛呀，我们就不去过做过多探讨了。我们学的就是啊我们学的就是儿童视角，你自己去再通过绿野仙踪和菊次郎的夏天给我好好的体会一下什么叫儿童视角，以及你需要写儿童片的时候，你自己。
怎么去创作这个东西，担忧什么期待什么害怕什么，小孩子到底在想什么？用这个角度去思考问题，这是我们这节课这部片子需要学的东西。